for day number seven we have a real pun
it's in this box here and I haven't done
read this one yet
it's from our Japanese fan Naga gasps
ooh now a science teacher and you can
see it's a fan so it's a periodic table
fan from a fan just in case you think I
can't see the picture on the back is
another periodic table I think this is
really beautiful and I showed the photo
of it in the lecture that I gave at the
beginning of November and in the
audience one of the people was the
master of the honorable company of fan
makers in the City of London they have
honorable companies or worshipful
companies that do all sorts of things
fan makers Horner's all sorts of things
so I sent him one of these for their
museum and in return he sent me a book
fans and fan makers and inside there is
a really nice dedication from the master
of the Worshipful company of fan makers
he also sent one of these books to Naga
Yasu Gnawa in Japan and he sent me a
copy of the letter so I think not only
did I get a really nice present but now
one of these fans is in the fan museum
in London so if you ever go there you'll
know about the periodic table we have a
periodic table fan from a
element six anthracite glowing plectrum
with strontium aluminate for drinking
receptacles three chemical pins two
periodic table bed covers and one piece
of tartaric acid from a Swiss wine
barrel what will be day eight
is that distance greatly compressed and
so all the distances are squashed in
that direction so as far as its
concerned the Earth's atmosphere is only
about 50 meters thick and it only has to
travel that 50 meters so actually has
time to get all the way from the top of
the atmosphere to do